what would you uh oh we got another we
got another one
this is this bracket right here this
fire back to back back to back backwards
these gravity stuff I want to grab a
leaf okay let me ask you a question
I saw her cutting the leaf up
so how long have you been smoking Grava
leaves
I go live because it feels like a lot to
like you gotta cut the [ __ ] open it is
but I personally I fly I've been smoking
probably like my whole time smoking it's
weird with that specifically like [ __ ]
might be smoking backwards now that's
the thing we smoke smoke grab them I
just thought smoking papers I'm trying
to get into that on some again all this
[ __ ] but I just want to grab it for a
long day of time you just call me all
the spices I feel like smoking papers is
like some kind some old people [ __ ] yeah
like my eyes can't take it no more or
whatever wow sorry dude no sorry
for me it's just a convenience thing
because I can't roll [ __ ] so if I go to
the store they have the cones
and you just grind your weed up you put
it in you just twist it and then you're
[ __ ] Off to the Races for me it's
like I like the whole process breaking
it down breaking down the grapple
rolling it up like that no the gravel
process is wild though because you'll
see someone pull out this giant dinosaur
batwing from a [ __ ] from a bag and
then start cutting [ __ ] pieces
but that's that's why [ __ ] started
smoking it though because like you get
five pack of Backwoods on like one of
them shits might be able to right you
get the Leaf you can just whatever size
it's efficient yeah literally it's
efficient it's interesting it's
efficient though it's like some DIY arts
and crafts it is it is for sure